what's gonna be different about the
season so the season is happening mm-hmm
and you guys are in spring training
summer camp 2.0 right now
and what's gonna be different about the
season first off they're telling us that
you only have a certain amount of guys
in the dugout which is weird because we
all sit in there and hang out and
[ __ ] and whatever during the games
so now they're saying if you're not
playing you have to sit in the stands so
there are gonna be fancy except they're
gonna be us we're not full uniforms oh
you should be a lot of this changing
more relaxing right I mean it's yeah
it's odd I told I talked to Kurt and I
thought they also said we can go home
which is like not something that has
ever been okay that's all I'm hey I may
never watch you there alive all year
he's what are you talking about I said
I'm just gonna sit in the pool oh
because you wouldn't even have to be
there because usually the bullpens there
and stuff you right the bullpen will
still be out there but us we'll just
starting pitchers usually sit right
there in the dugout and kind of hang out
so we can leave damn it's almost like
you think you'll miss that part yeah you
know what's weird is in Asia leave
that's like standard operating procedure
for them so they leave what like if
they're not pitching they're not there
yeah they go in during them you know
during the afternoon get their stuff
done an hour before the game they just
head out but we had a Korean guy hunch
Andrew that he like hated watching games
cuz he'd never done it it's not life and
then he comes in America and like
expected to stay forever dude I'm not
kidding you that guy would be out of the
locker room within five minutes of the
last Alf only thing showered at the
field I think he just threw [ __ ] on a
roll no he's like I'm not even pay for
this I want to go to dinner tell me a
little bit more about some of the new
rules that are gonna be going on okay so
they're saying we can't spit number one
so you watch a baseball game you you
know people spit cuz it does yeah that's
gonna be interesting they're saying
instead of spitting we're gonna have a
wet rag in our back pocket so we can
touch that and then go to the ball
because you need a little moisture
sometimes so we'll see how long that one
lasts I think obviously the dugout stuff
because someone's gonna spin immediately
just by Nature yeah you don't even know
you do it yeah you know you just spit
so that'll be interesting is it a
penalty if you spare this game be like
somebody saying hey I think they can
find you know yeah buying you I don't
understand why it would be a financial
thing I think it's a bacteria in the air
they believe I also know that if you hit
a ground ball and more than two guys hit
touch the ball so you threw it third
baseman catches it throws the first
baseman three guys touch it gotta get a
new ball oh yeah it's gonna be a while
the unharmed blowtrotters yeah and so
are you concerned about how um and now
hold on there's more rules though - I
read one that there is because I didn't
know about these so but there's one
where if you guys you guys aren't gonna
bat anymore
correct so the pitchers will no longer
bat yes which is a good thing bad thing
it's all it's all good at bat because I
like the hit but we all suck ok so
there's there's two pitchers maybe they
can actually really hit I don't have any
of them no offense to Kirsch or any of
those guys none of our guys okay so but
now I got to face another actual hitter
I don't get to face myself which is kind
of a freebie a lot of the time so yeah
so a lot of those guys in because the
American League they have they have the
D H already so they have the the pitcher
never bats right so they have nine
professional hitters so they have a so
American league pitchers it's harder for
them to get a no-hitter for sure 100%
dang it's not easy regardless right
easier in the National League probably
okay so I'm just thinking about these
rules this is so insane dude I almost
feel like now I'm at the rodeo and it's
almost like we're not playing baseball
playing like wiffle ball but okay so now
also there's a rule if you guys go to
extra innings that they're gonna put
someone on second base yeah so that that
they've been doing that in the minor
leagues for a long time okay kind of
testing it out it'll JT actually came
out and said he wanted homerun Derby
Annelise no Justin Turner our third
baseman big red beard guy okay he said
he wants a homerun Derby to break the
break the next ratings which I love I
think it'd be hysterical at the end of
the game
myself tired hit homer and that's what
the ex ratings really are because
everybody wants to hit the walk-up so
everyone just ready at home runs all the
time in extra
anyway so they've done this rule with
the guy in second forever in the minor
leagues trying to figure it out and now
we're gonna give it a go in the big
leagues I guess but it'll be interesting
do you have any thought yeah like what
are your thoughts on it I luckily have
never had to start an inning that I
didn't let somebody on base and they
just stuck somebody out there but
there'd be pressure right out the gate
cuz that guy's already there yeah and
then there's like a million different
strategies you know you can bond or
whatever to try and get him to third so
you can score easier and it might be
cool it might be a way for a pitcher
finally get back in the batter's box Oh
cuz pitchers are pretty pretty good
bunner's typically and but but you are
but even if your team doesn't get to bat
first you still get the bottom of that
inning right yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz
that almost seems like man you could
easily get the yeah maybe don't make it
a little more exciting it might because
sometimes these games just go on forever
we had that World Series game two years
ago that went 17 innings through the
first seven of it I was at the ballpark
longer not playing that was then I threw
the ball really good it was just took
forever we played should I got home at
like 3:00 in the morning there any other
expectations you have going into the
season does it feel like going into a
regular season like absolutely not okay
it can't we've been sitting home for
three months you know I mean so I don't
know well I hope we get all our games in
that'd be the biggest thing in the
playoffs and all that but with this and
all the new kovetz around I get you know
I don't know what's gonna happen
yeah and they are planning on traveling
yeah so what they did normally we play
every national team so we go to the east
coast back and forth all the time which
sucks because we get screwed on the time
stuff but we're only playing I think
we're only playing like that the NL West
so our division and the AOS so we're
kind of staying out here which will be
nice travel wise yeah you know what I
mean instead of six hours flight six
hour flights to Washington and [ __ ] like
that so that's so they're making it easy
that way there'll be nobody in the
stands correct what do you think like is
that kind of is everybody still gonna
care about the game as much it takes
some of the ego out of it almost yeah it
takes some of the energy out of it for
sure you know like I think a lot of
teams time up
crowd noise or pumping crowd noise in
there so it feels a little bit oh yeah
more like it I saw in Korea they're
using sex dolls Stan yeah some teams I
heard or you can pay 50 bucks and get a
cardboard cutout of yourself put in the
stadium which is kind of interesting
yeah I thought of that idea no but
they're doing some they're doing some
wacky stuff especially over there in
Korea Wow
yes those were sex dolls cheering on a
South Korean soccer team yeah I think
they got in trouble for that why some
loser takes our ha and they're wearing
masks it's an interesting to God and
they're six feet apart
yeah that's an interesting one Wow
someone social-media go back up to the
top if you don't mind Nick over the
weekend mannequins were replacing the
stands for a match against wangju FC
someone's lost immunity that telltale
signs business logos for sex toy
marketers tried to add some funny says
fun in the no spectator match I like it
kind of I love the idea of having
somebody be able to send a pitcher in or
like daughter cells put in the stands
like for a certain like I said you could
do it as a gift to somebody you know
like you're there yeah happy birthday
with three and toddler station and maybe
somebody doesn't want to be there it's
like grandma you know imagine open that
for Christmas it just says you have a
cardboard cutout yeah you never get to
see it and watch a game but you might
catch a glimpse of getting one of those
stars it's like somebody botanists are
like oh thanks acid some sea otter yeah
yeah I have to go outdoors at night I
live in a dangerous neighborhood we just
make a landed that's a good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one